escuché un ruido horrible y nadie sabía
lo que estaba pasando realmente en ese
momento mi mamá volteo para ver si
estaba en el asiento de atrás y para su
sorpresa yo ya no estaba
y apenas tenía un año y medio ha bajado
a seguir a mi papá que se había bajado
del coche a su vez que había dejado por
supuesto sin querer la puerta abierta
conoce la calle nadie sabía que pasaba
un coche se había metido en sentido
contrario me golpeó me aventó contra la
banqueta y del golpe rebote a media
avenida y el coche al huir me pasó por
arriba mi mamá desesperada me tomó en
sus brazos y todo ensangrentadas asur el
coche con mi papá y se fueron
despavoridos al hospital al llegar al
hospital la sangre de atlanta que
creyeron que ella era la que se había
accidentado y la metieron a ella en vez
de amigos
toda la confusión y por supuesto
fueron meses muy difíciles
la verdad no sé como la libre pero aquí
estoy
muchísima gente pensaba que no iba a
volver a caminar por alguna razón sin
explicación dejé de caminar
aproximadamente un año
los doctores hacían evaluaciones
constantes tanto del cerebro como
físicas todo estaba enojado
al final la conclusión es que todo
estaba en mi mente
deje de caminar y de pronto volvió a
caminar y entendí
que todo estaba en mi mente
muy probablemente esa fue la primera vez
que tenía todas las apuestas en mi
contra
muy probablemente esa fue uno de los
momentos que marcaron mi vida
mi idea siguió transcurriendo normal
creciera una familia sin muchos lujos
pero tampoco sin carencias todo
transcurría de una manera como lo
conocemos normal
cuando decidí ir a la universidad
habiendo crecido en la ciudad de mexico
decidir estudiar al tec de monterrey en
monterrey
dejé mi casa y me fui
toda la felicidad me fui con mis amigos
normal seguir transcurriendo mi vida
normal
después del segundo año de universidad
lo que sucedió volvió a hacer una
apuesta en mi contra llegue a ser el
verano a méxico y para mi sorpresa me
encontré con que mi familia había caído
en un proceso estábamos totalmente va a
empresario de toda la vida y como todos
los empresarios pasó por una racha muy
mal y de pronto todo cambió no pude
regresar a estudiar a monterrey
y yo sentía que mi vida se había acabado
seguramente esa fue la segunda vez que
todas las apuestas estuvieron en mi
contra
mis amigos de monterrey apostaban que
hacer un fracasar
yo seguí adelante busque una universidad
y volví a empezar desde cero
arranque a estudiar ingeniería civil por
segunda vez
estaba llevando clases en 5º 4º 3º 2º
todo estaba hecho un desastre trabajado
por la mañana y ver la escuela mediodía
y regresaba a trabajar
así transcurrieron los cinco años de
universidad
tenía una novia a la cual quise
muchísimo
pero extraordinaria estudiante
estuve con ella desde antes de arrancar
el tec de monterrey durante mi estancia
por la universidad de méxico
y al término de la universidad me
encontré con que la situación financiera
en casa no había mejorado
sigue habiendo problemas económicos y
por supuesto lo que yo ganaba no era
suficiente para pagar la universidad
nuevamente sentí que ninguno se acababa
porque no me podía graduar si no pagaba
en la universidad y no podía pagar la
universidad sino me gradué
estaba en un círculo vicioso sin salida
en donde yo creía que no había más
futuro para mí y que yo estaba destinado
a ser un fracasado
sin embargo esta novia de la que les
hablo al ser tan buena estudiante
recibió mención honorífica y mejor por
medio de generación entregado por el
rector de la universidad en el patio
central un evento grandísimo al que por
supuesto yo fui como asistente a recibir
solamente mi constancia de que había
terminado los estudios pero no el
permiso para graduarnos
cuando mi esposa estaba recibiendo su
reconocimiento le dijo al rector mi
novio quiere hablar contigo y después
llegó conmigo y me dijo corre que tienes
cita con el rector y estaba yo enfrente
del rector sin saber cómo siendo le es
la segunda vez que quiero ser ingeniero
civil y no sé cómo por favor ayudar
entonces qué cara habré tenido no sé
cómo lo habré hecho
pero al poco tiempo me llamó y me dijo
seguramente en 30 meses vas a ganar
mucho más de lo que ganas ahora me hizo
un plan de pagos a 30 meses y el mes 31
tenía que pagar la mitad del cerebro
habló al director de finanzas de la
universidad y me dio permiso de titular
ese hito nuevamente dio un giro
importantísimo
seguí adelante me titulé efectivamente
conseguí un buen trabajo en una
multinacional y empecé a trabajar
y divina empezó a mejorar sin embargo no
hacía lo que me toca trabajaba y van
creciendo empecé a ser considerado en
esta multinacional como un rey stands
empecé a crecer a brincar de un puesto a
otro empezaron a asignar nuevas tareas y
mejores nuestros habilidades
hasta que en un punto por alguna razón
el presidente de la empresa decidió
hacer un proceso de innovación interna y
empezar a buscar oportunidades de
negocio para la empresa y me dieron a mí
la responsabilidad de buscarlas empecé a
viajar por el mundo estando por angola
formal y por burkina faso por el congo
encontré algo que yo nunca había visto
porque mis puntos de referencia de
distintos me encontré con una realidad
distinta me encontré con un mundo de
pobreza que yo honestamente nunca había
visto regresé conmovido a méxico decidir
hacer algo para crear un negocio o una
propuesta para atender a la pobreza en
él mismos
empecé después a viajar y entender un
poco más la pobreza primero en méxico lg
por chiapas viaje por oaxaca viaje por
barco estaba amigo por la sierra de
guerrero
por puebla con la sierra negra
y empecé a encontrar algo que hoy parece
bastante obvio pero en ese entonces no
lo era es un mundo de pobreza extrema
impera en este país
conmovido me puse a investigar todavía
más y me encontré con un dato todavía
peor que es este contraste tan terrible
que existe entre la riqueza y la pobreza
los que vivimos en la ciudad de méxico
sabemos perfecto
que no importa en donde vivas basta con
abrir la ventana y puedes ver un
contraste terrible pero también me di
cuenta que estamos siendo observados
todo el tiempo por todo el mundo
los ricos observan a los pobres pero los
pobres observan también a los ricos y
esta brecha que se empieza a abrir a
veces no la entendemos o no la queremos
ver y si dejamos que esa brecha se abra
suben demasiado se puede convertir en un
tema muy peligroso man en la cima del
mundo pero sobre todo en una injusticia
que no podemos permitir
hay datos importantísimos que empecé a
encontrar sobre la distribución de la
riqueza y solamente por mencionar uno me
encontré en manos de quien está la
riqueza solamente el punto 7 por ciento
de la población tiene más del 40% de la
riqueza disponible a nivel mundial
mientras que más del 50% de la población
solamente tiene menos del 3 por ciento
de la riqueza disponible eso es
increíble
esta es la distribución de la riqueza es
lo que ha hecho que el mundo se dispare
tanto se polaricen tanto había que hacer
algo
regresé con mis jefes hacerles una
propuesta para hacer un modelo de
negocio basado en mi experiencia como
primero si bien para hacer descansos a
los más necesitados
sin embargo por alguna razón en ese
momento la estrategia de la empresa no
estaba alineada con eso probablemente
hice mal mi tarea probablemente no es
suficientemente fuerte el pips no lo sé
el hecho es que el proyecto no me lo
aprobaron
nuevamente lo que sentí una gran
frustración y nuevamente sentí que las
apuestas estaban en mi contra y que yo
no estaba destinado a cumplir mis sueños
pero por primera vez tomé control de la
situación y decidí dejar una carrera de
nueve años en la ascendencia clara con
un futuro que todo el mundo apostaba por
lo menos dentro de la empresa de
crecimiento
hice mis maletas y decidí hacer caso a
una frase que dijo hace tiempo
central o todo lo que se emparenta puede
cambiar pero nada va a cambiar hasta que
se enfrenten
y decidí enfrentar
y decidí poner manos a la obra
y empezar a entender mucho más cómo
poder cambiar el mundo
así fue como hice la primera empresa
social
empezamos haciendo casas para los más
necesitados
empezamos con un modelo de negocio
porque yo creía que la rentabilidad y el
impacto social pueden convivir en
armonía y una empresa que no crece
desaparece por lo tanto lo que pensé es
cómo poder crear una empresa
autosostenible y ayudar a la vez empecé
a trabajar con la gente de cerca para
enseñarles a hacer sus casas
poco a poco empezamos a fortalecer el
modelo y poco a poco fuimos entendiendo
más y más y más
hasta que de pronto
nos encontramos haciendo una cosa
increíble nos encontramos con que
efectivamente empezamos a cambiar guías
entonces nos empezamos a hacer más
preguntas
cómo poder hacer esto más grande cómo
poder retar el status quo cómo poder
dejar de pensar global de actuar local y
empezar a pensar global y actuar global
porque la pobreza no tiene pasaportes
la pobreza no sabe de colores la pobreza
no sabe de religión ni de muros
un pobre su pobre no importa en donde
haya tenido el infortunio de nacer y los
que tenemos la fortuna de haber nacido
no porque lo escogimos sino porque
solamente así así sucedió
tenemos que hacer algo al respecto
pero sobre todo dejar de pensar
solamente en vivienda y empezar a pensar
en algo muchísimo más integral porque lo
que entendí es que lo que verdaderamente
estaba haciendo no eran casas lo que
entendí es que lo que estaba haciendo
era conectar la riqueza con la base de
la pirámide
era hablar pobre y hablar linda
era poder ser este signo de comunicación
entre la gente que tiene posibilidades
de creación de valor y la gente que
tienen necesidades de creación de valor
y entonces lo que pensé es que podíamos
crear un verdadero estilo social cuando
pensamos en un skate lo pensamos en una
empresa de tecnología pero por qué no
pensar en un skate lo social
existe tanta necesidad que podemos
crecer las empresas de una manera
exponencial y hacer el bien a la vez
tiempo después regresé a buscar al
rector de la universidad con esa novia
de las que les platiqué
con la cual decidí casarme y pasar el
resto de mi vida y hoy tenemos un poco
más de 25 años juntos
regresamos a ver lo que invitamos a
comer y lo que le dijimos es que no
había ayudado a una pareja a realizar
sus sueños había ayudado a gente en
méxico en guatemala en eeuu
en salvador en honduras en nicaragua
cambiar su vida había ayudado a más de
500.000 personas a tener una casa había
ayudado a más de 70.000 familias a tener
un techo digno a más de 17 mil personas
a recibir asistencia técnica a más de
400 personas a tener un departamento
libro en eeuu a más de más de 15 mil
familias tomar agua pura
lo que había hecho no había sido cambiar
una o dos vidas había tenido un impacto
increíble
entonces entendí que no importa las
acciones que tengamos tenemos que
hacerlas lo más grandes posibles porque
no tenemos idea del impacto que pueden
tener nuestra sanción
y finalmente lo que decidí es hacerlo en
grande
si lo que hacemos no lo hacemos en
grande mejor no lo hagamos vayamos
grande o regresemos a casa
hace mucho 100 hace muchos años cuenta
la leyenda que existía un guerrero
un guerrero decidido atravesar la luna
con su lanza
cada vez que se ponía el sol y salía la
luna este guerrero se había decidido
atravesar la luna con su lanza y así
pasaban los días y los días y los días
el guerrero practicaba y práctica
por supuesto el guerrero murió y nunca
fue capaz de atravesar la luna con su
lanza pero nunca ha existido un guerrero
que haya lanzado su lanza más lejos
tenemos que ser como ese guerrero todo
lo que hagamos tenemos que hacerlo
apuntando a la luz y soñar en grande
porque si tus sueños no te dan miedo es
que no estás soñando lo suficientemente
grandes